pretty good i don't laugh i don't find
things funny
[Music]
hi guys i'm greg i'm aaron
yeah yeah we're gonna do a try not to
laugh challenge today
spider-man into the spider-verse
unnecessary censorship from the channel
ninja panda don't really do try not to
laugh that often we're gonna do a family
guy one but then i was like you know the
hardest
ones are actually unnecessary
censorships considering that
aaron and i have talked so much marvel
in dc throughout our entire friendship
i was like let's do this one which
sounds like a lot of fun i don't even
know who spiderman is
well you should the last one in the
animated one was a black guy
what's a black guy
i i don't know i should look that up
shouldn't i
yeah i should find one
are you creating this [ __ ] already
successful
now remember if you end up laughing just
start again
there's no money involved because that's
the only time to take competition
[Laughter]
seriously
thanks to everyone here at the fisk
family
every choice that we make you don't mean
back in the day
[Music]
no okay
yes i'm pretty sure you know the rest
you see
the city fell in love i got married the
city some more maybe too much
been like 15 years past blah blah blah
super boring i broke my back a drone
my face i buried at may my wife and i
split up and i got a lot of time to
reflect and myself
two horses that they mate
could you imagine a seahorse eating
another see ours
and then making it work step five
download the important stuff i'll note
when i see
[Music]
[Music]
there's three actually no this is good
this is very very good this means you
get what you want
in my universe it's 1933 and i'm a
private owner i like the
nazis a lot sometimes i let mattress
burn down to my
just to feel something anything i'm a
photographer for the daily vegan when
i'm not poaching around i'm looking like
a dog
okay little fella keep in mind first of
all
i'm talking hard boys well i i haven't
actually [ __ ] anyone surprised
i'm scared man i'm just
tired and everybody you're the only
working
i just wish you were here i know the kid
he's got what it takes i bet he's going
to come back through that door
recharged and ready to my uncle miles
damn straight about this job
you can't always everybody that's not
true
i'm spider-man i need you to come with
me i
i just told you that listen listen i'm
from the future dare you
me you you were first don't take life
too seriously
oh i was so short damn
that worked way too well
where's that alternate version give me
that movie
spider-man into the first
[Laughter]
everybody swear a lot now because we'll
just bleep it all out
man yeah man
spider it's funny because whenever i see
these it doesn't just change the context
of the scene
it changes the whole plot
every single time it becomes about
the problems come down to [ __ ] and
then the solutions come down to
you're really gonna [ __ ] you out of this
exact one every single time and it's
funny they keep using the same joke
literally every time before you know
you're pulled into this like
weird soap opera narrative about like
incest
weird intertwining love circles
weird fetishes it's the same experience
every time i watch these i start off
with this is so funny to now i'm
watching some
weird movies and the music changes the
context too
it's like yeah the dart it becomes like
this weird dark erotic
thing you can't always [ __ ] everything
i [ __ ] the city some more
[Laughter]
this is really hard stuff to do actually
you think about it because you do got to
go through
beat by beat of every line and make sure
because at first
when this ended i was like wow that's so
short i feel like you could have done
the whole movie at the same time it's
like
you probably do have to really find the
right lines where the joke
hits hard hard every single time
you know what i mean it actually takes a
lot of
a weird amount of precision i'd imagine
like this might seem like an easy thing
to do
but i think actually no that's really
challenging
i'm one under every five men very bad at
it
like i heard he goes in the butt i heard
there's a thing about like
self-deprecating and then there's just
being honest
i gotta tell you if anyone has ever been
sexually attracted to me
i'm what you call a disappointment in
the bedroom
i always end satisfied
but yeah it's uh you know
it's really hard to get encounters
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
it's okay spiderman well one day right
[Laughter]
well i feel like they could do a
spider-man into the verse one day
because there's that age-old joke about
how
spider-man shoots out webs from his [ __ ]
they should have that version whenever
spider-man is officially just tanking at
sony and they just really have no more
faith
they should do a hard r into the spider
versus
that version of spider-man use that
angel and theme song
it was whenever a spider
it's a web anytime i was also watching
this footage i was going i forgot how
good this movie was yeah yeah
this is great anyway guys make sure to
subscribe to ninja panda as soon as you
can this was a really
fun ass video all right guys if you
haven't subscribed in japan and make
sure to do it as soon as you can
subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell follow
aaron alexander on instagram
catch you guys on the flippity flip flip
flip catch on the flippity [ __ ]